i don't know
i mean i think you know logan i don't i
don't know joe um but he seems like a
guy who really knows who he is
um and
uh the problem he has and you know this
dave we've talked about this
if you don't have your own platform and
even with your own platform
amazon can
cut you off
um the banks can cut you off
if you don't have your own platform
where are you gonna go
he just traded youtube which would have
kicked him off by now traded youtube and
all those views and easy access without
a paywall he traded that to go over to
spotify
he was smart enough to make sure that
they're paying him money doesn't talk it
screams
a hundred million dollars
screams to him but it also screams to
spotify you don't flush that down the
toilet
so okay so it is about control we're in
the beginnings of it do you see any
markers
that show us the way out of this so for
example as we're taping this right now
there is a massive probably the biggest
world war worldwide convoy of trucks
happening in canada right now in protest
of these mandates of these lockdowns
which is directly connected obviously to
everything else you're talking about
here that's pretty good right that's
pretty good that's great and it is those
things that will stop it but what has to
be stopped the most important thing that
cannot get its roots any deeper
if you're an investor a 401k and let's
say you have your 401k through you know
uh
i don't know jpmorgan or whatever
i want you to go to your website and see
look for esg scores
and i think it's charles schwab that has
the esg score for your account
and when i've talked about this
i think it was bank of america or city
one of the banks called and said no no
that's not what esgs are about we're
never going to use them for people and i
said then why is your subsidiary using
it
on
my account why do i have an esg score
and they said well that's because we're
doing that because a lot of people
really care about social justice and
environment and governance of the boards
and so we're just helping them know who
they're investing in and i said you're
so full of crap you can't see through
the brown in your eyes for the love of
pete
now they are clear on this esg
has to be stopped right now because that
is the control of your business of your
money of absolutely everything in your
life it is your social credit score and
it is starting at the bank level for
businesses all of the big businesses
they're all in on esg
uh warning that is the fascistic system
that will trickle down to you
and glenn call me crazy but do you think
they might be able to link something
like an esg score to perhaps a vaccine
passport would is that something a crazy
person might that's why the passport on
the vaccine passport is so important you
know i was talking to one of those
truckers that was in canada and he had
to deliver something to the united
states he has to have the app on his
phone that he shows
uh and you know you just scan the qr
he got to the border for the canadian
crossing he went to to the united states
and then turned around after he dropped
his load and he was coming uh back into
canada he had his phone on the qr code
and he was ready to put it out the
window and uh and to show it to the guy
he rolls the window down he starts
moving towards and the guy goes no i got
that uh you're okay go ahead and he said
wait a minute aren't you supposed to
scan this and he said no
um and i don't remember the distance but
it was like you know when you're within
a quarter of a mile all of that is
transmitted to us we know exactly who
you are
holy cow and by the way if you think
this is nuts it has gotten so bad in
china that you cannot leave your house
without your phone
if you do
the facial recognition finds you they
send the police out to you to say go
back to your house and get your phone
it is such a part of life now you you've
heard the amber alert
that's what happens when you start to
approach someone who has a low credit
score
if you have a low social credit score
everybody's phone around that person
warns them don't get any closer or it'll
affect your score
this stuff with joe rogan
is not about covid it's not it's about
silencing any kind of descent and if
they win with rogan
we're gone we're gone so we covered that
on my show this morning i i said it is
the biggest cultural and political story
of the day it is and i mean by the way i
don't mean literally today i mean right
now it is the biggest thing because it's
a marker for everything do you think
rogan's going to be able to stand up to
this thing because you know he gave a
pretty good uh pushback but they are
spotify now is putting disclaimers in
front of his videos which he said he
welcomed uh so do you think do you think
he can fight here's the thing i i don't
know
i mean i think you know logan i don't i
don't know joe um but he seems like a
guy who really knows who he is
um and
uh the problem he has and you know this
dave we've talked about this
if you don't have your own platform
and even with your own platform
amazon can
cut you off
um the banks can cut you off
if you don't have your own platform
where are you gonna go
he just traded youtube which would have
kicked him off by now traded youtube and
all those views and easy access without
a paywall he traded that to go over to
spotify
he was smart enough to make sure that
they're paying him money doesn't talk it
screams
a hundred million dollars
screams to him but it also screams to
spotify you don't flush that down the
toilet
can he make some adjustments to his show
yeah he shouldn't we should all be
outraged that the federal government the
only reason why spotify did anything
they don't care about joni mitchell for
the love of nobody
joni mitchell's family doesn't care
about joni mitchell
so
it's it's not that it's that the surgeon
general came out
and on advice from the white house
and said this is dangerous to people and
you know social media and spotify they
need to step up their game well that is
the very
clear definition of a violation of the
first amendment there's the government
using their power to coerce somebody to
do something
i i i don't know dave if he survives i
hope he does
um but this is
kovid is only the pregame
financial
is the real game and when our economy
starts to collapse
the great reset people back in december
did a uh a nine or ten day
war game on a financial collapse and the
first thing that they did was they had
to silence the people
who were saying anything other than the
official truth
and what they were saying was these
people are going to get the entire
financial system globally to collapse
you've got to shut them up and those
people were saying i don't think i
believe the bank on this this or this or
maybe you should get your money out of
the bank because bank holidays are
coming all of those things are true
as they wargamed but they will silence
us
quickly
the move that the
surgeon general made that comment that
he made that you know that the big tech
companies they should look into this
sort of thing is very consistent with
what this administration did i'm sure
you saw the video i'm sure you covered
it when gen saki a couple months back
yeah we flag things for facebook we
i mean have they just have they just
figured out a way around the first
amendment at this point i mean does the
first amendment is
what they just did is against the the
first amendment well it's not a law in
other words have they just figured out
the wink and it works that you don't
need to pass a law yeah so that is the
thing about the great reset
everyone is a stakeholder
and it is a complete end run around the
constitution around all governments it
is an amazing thing
by the way he's still pushing his build
back better uh uh package
guess who else is doing that right now
uh england has a build back better
package almost the same i think france
does as well germany has one as well and
they're all exactly the same
uh it's just how open and honest are you
going to be on what it's going to cost
we're saying that it's free
i think germany is saying yeah we're
going to tax the snot out of you if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell